[Music]
all right in company submitted by myself
surprises employees with a holiday bonus
you chose this oh really not to not to
give a holiday bonus or what's the
what's the underlining issue wait he
didn't get offended offended he was just
saying you're dropping a hit like it was
her no continue it and be like oh she
could I should offense no I was just
like yeah I was like damn I I see what
you're doing here I caught you you sly
bastards like there's a holiday bonus
extend to the guests I heard it's good
for myself so this might be Amazon right
Amazon's let me do this because they may
bank that needs person would get like to
be like the cheapest company on the area
no yeah I thought that was just dizzy
like Disney was the cheaper yeah
they overworked their employees for like
then okay pain yeah Amazon's main thing
is just about customer first like what's
the best price we had a lot of summers
but exactly so for us is great but like
for the people who work for them yeah
man why would you I mean like I love the
service so it's like if I'm sitting here
and going like yeah you know they should
treat their employees better it's like
well do I want to pay more money exactly
you gonna pay more because I'm enjoying
Amazon like a [ __ ] I heard it
like when you go to the restaurant you
have to have your own roll of toilet you
say Amazon because they don't have that
paper holders yeah they got stalls but
there's actually no toilet in the stores
just a bucket it's like a drum it's like
a that's what it's worth it though
because you get stuff the same day yeah
yeah oh my god it's like magic it is
magic they surprised there 198 employees
with a 10 million dollar bonus honest I
said good amount yeah we even got the
same amount because they they ended up
dividing it based off of like how long
they've been seniority how long they've
been working at the company and so
they're saying that the average employee
is getting about 50,000 dollars each but
because it depends on their tenure and
years of service some employees are
getting six-figure bonuses upwards of
250 thousand dollars they're doing it
the right way that's how you get
customers I mean employees for like
double ride-or-die for the company like
I'm retiring here because none of the
company does not work for I would have a
rider down forever I would snitch so
fast some Banana Republic and journeys
I'm telling everything
you want to pay for my wardrobe for the
rest of my life your banana republic i
was banana with a lot of people from
Apple who came from Banana Republic yeah
all right no let's realize that that's
like I was thinking about Colorado
Pasadena my they're always like
next-door to each other just like patent
Express and Baja Fresh so the same
stories yeah all right so I have a video
to show you guys of the moment they
surprise their employees and my I mean
work are they doing the company is
called st. John properties we love real
estate oh here we go
oh so it's awesome you know I think even
jokey diverse
that's cultural appropriation red
envelopes
now I'm not caught that the Chinese with
that grandma dying cuz it's so big the
government never cashed it yeah that bad
way out what if you're one of the guys
that opened the envelope and you don't
get that reaction somebody else you over
your ever loved life look everybody's
like talking to each other [ __ ] 300 I
feel like a chump because I remember
when I got my first like raised at Apple
because they were it was doing it was a
company-wide raise whenever and I'm
still used to like at that point working
minimum wage so like that and they told
me like oh we're bringing up to like
twenty something or I'm like what I
haven't that reaction they're like $20 a
Polly good about the pay their boys and
at that point they wouldn't even hire
them they usually do that I was like
what is this amazing valiantly wasn't
like that but I had that same reaction
and face stuff of like a five-dollar
increasing we saw five zeroes behind and
then a decimal I leave my okay I have
got some decent checks for like working
and [ __ ] like that but like my biggest
checks that still come from like tax
returns right so like I was talking to a
friend who gets paid handsomely off of
like YouTube and Facebook they sure like
then he told me what he made like one
month and like I didn't know what I knew
people making money but I didn't know
the process like money monetizing and
stuff like that when he told me I was
just like you made the worry about the
clutter you did clutch my pearls I was I
was Baba's flapper guys because like
nobody shared the information on how to
do it so I'm like I just feel well first
of all I need to re-evaluate my friend
that's cuz a lot of the even Kevin Kevin
you didn't tell me how to do this so you
know we're gonna fight when I see you
cuz my other friend told me and he's
like yeah man you should have been doing
this I've been qualified on face
look at YouTube I got to watch hours of
this wouldn't putting that up so yeah
man not you know you have been no wait
yeah now that I know I'm still waiting
on Facebook I guess I get the emails
first I can submit all my tax
information and all of that but then
yeah yeah then that's gonna change the
game because like once you start making
money like that like like I got an
audition today an audition I had to go
through they wanted me to bring a resume
and a hair sounds like fail I'm gonna
act as an access and la casting you
could pull both of those so but now I
have to go to FedEx to get something
printed out that I want to use maybe
once or twice a year physically right
yeah and then you go in his room you're
sending this waking room with 5 or 6
people that look like you y'all fight
for the same point but if I'm making 30
to 50 thousand dollars a month off for
Facebook and YouTube I won't give a [ __ ]
if I get this point I'm making my own
content I just create mom she didn't put
it up there and I don't have to wait for
somebody say yeah let's give this guy a
try like this is ridiculous so I can't
we're gonna be on Facebook soon Oh Jane
you guys do let him put on there yeah
but we don't have the videos on yet okay
yeah is that a weird experience for you
being an audition and seeing like six of
you are they like the same personality
to somebody that sometimes it just looks
similar sometimes with completely
different sometimes is weird cuz people
they know you they'll a man what are you
doing here trying to make it we just saw
you do not rich if I was rich I would
not be in here this is a one line
audition
I feel like in traditional media like
that if that's your only grind there's a
lot of like inside competition with my
group but then on on social media or
like digital like we all benefit from
each other mm-hmm so there's no like
people talking behind each other's backs
and like all the bait they [ __ ] got
the role [ __ ] yeah I don't care like I
know what's been meant for me is for me
like nobody can take something away from
me that I was supposed to have so I
never like have any type of hated malice
or 20 anyone off of that but I wish I
had known earlier about this Facebook
Rises I
I was broke for a month and I didn't
have to me wait so then why are you
upset with cuz you tell me you're more
meant to have that money until now bucks
I know but I don't want to put it down
if I didn't really have intentions then
way to make I was like yeah yeah I know
it's 21 it's about to come out 21
unbreakable window the full option is
2022 with the three motor all wheel
drive that's what the long-range right
that one goes like 300 miles all right
no rush bucket at that time it might be
another company out there doing it way
better so they use red envelopes it's
like out of all the colors Christmas
times holiday time see it it's not
Chinese New Year envelope or cream wait
what you want to be greeting us on my
dad hears you guys agree or a gold one
cars come in a red envelope they're
always red usually whatever oh yeah it's
ready maybe in a Harry Potter fan I
would think that's a howler if someone's
about the Yeller I mean you're something
like that I'm up you're fired
how alert see this is why I need my
geeky friends I didn't know they were
called I watched it I just forget you're
the only true one you'd only want to
keep a real she was like I was waiting
for you finish your sentence you did he
was talking
you didn't know that [ __ ] oh hey you
have so many little references to
sometimes I don't you the comments I
know y'all hear me when I be the
reference they're like what the voice of
the kiss hand I'm gonna like this
relieve might I watched every single
Harry Potter exercise out there sure
fart and jog do I surprise each other
with your holiday bonuses no we actually
don't take a bonus during holidays no we
for go our own cut and give it to you no
no I wouldn't anyone know that why would
anyone know how selfless we are but you
see us operate 365 days a year
but why would anyone know what happens
behind the scenes between two people I
don't know I thought we said that out
loud in the past but no one else here
caught that I didn't catch it
that's my understanding so we got
started this you guys up man I love
Kevin Family Center I know man I don't
know why we did it that way I should
have been by monopoly man like I should
have been like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you get out
of here now we got to talk about
feelings and friendships and all this
man is growing I know this girl man
that's why we I want to work outside to
lose weight but I also like to be the
best version of me that's why I started
going to therapy
it's like I was I was I was totally
against Caterpie growing up like
especially a blackout so they're like
you don't go out telling the family's
business
like you never like get past some things
that you've been holding on to and
harbor and now it's build up layers
until you like start to address that so
fast you want to be the best version of
me I could be I don't fully remember my
buddy was like hey I'm going if they're
of your mic you just talk into a person
he's like yeah just talking it really is
that but I think even that helps I just
think they guide your thoughts in your
motion that's like where did it come
from how does it make you feel
is everything talking for me it's like a
brain right yeah it's like I'm talking
to an unbiased friend who does not yeah
I might be it yeah they don't
necessarily give you instructions or
anything like on what you should do with
no agenda just yeah there's no it's no
hidden agenda and then but the [ __ ] is
offensive this mother [ __ ] our grip
pistol lean back and just be like
[Music]